JULIAN ZELIZER: Johnson, as
we've studied, was a creature
of Congress.
He was a man who
loved Congress.
He loved legislating.
And he defined his legacy very
much by what he could you get
Congress to do.
I will go into class, and
sometimes I will have a
perspective that I've had
in my head on a subject.
And I've had many moments when
students have changed that.
They've just seen the argument
very differently, and they've
challenged me.
JACK MARZULI: Professor
Zelizer is very
connected to politics.
And before I even started
taking the
class, I Googled him.
And you immediately get 10s
and 10s of hits of him in
relevant modern political
contexts.
EMILY CARTER: Five years ago,
I decided I was going to my
entire research program
to work on
problems related to energy.
I felt that my expertise in
developing and applying
quantum mechanics-based methods
could, in fact, be
reoriented to the planet to
a sustainable future.
There has to be a huge effort in
research into moving onto a
sustainable path.
There's an amazing number
of opportunities for
undergraduate research in energy
and the environment.
I'm researching magnesium
batteries.
They are an alternative to
lithium ion batteries.
There's so much more magnesium,
it's about four
times more abundant than lithium
in the Earth's crust.
All right, great.
JEFF NUNOKAWA: My role at
Rockefeller college is to be
incredibly lucky recipient of
some of the best intellectual
energy and social joy
that I've ever been
in the midst of.
We have students who are
extraordinarily acute and
generous socially.
We have students who are
extraordinarily acute and
generous in more measurable,
intellectual ways.
I like teaching Victorian
literature because I think it
helps us understand a little
bit about how much our
inexhaustible faith in the idea
of romance, how rooted
this is in the novels of
an earlier century.